spider-man likes to blame the bad things
that happen to him and what he calls the
old parker luck
but honestly it might just be karma
after all peter parker has done all
kinds of awful things over the years
and these are some of the very worst
over time the pre-spider bite version
peter parker has become known as a bit
of a lovable loser but if you actually
go back and reread amazing fantasy
number 15
he's actually just a run of the milk
jerk yes old puny parker gets more than
his fair share of abuse from flash
thompson
and midtown heights ruling elite but his
sinister response to their taunts
is more reminiscent of a budding future
criminal than a soon-to-be superhero
pete's revenge fantasies don't end when
he acquires superpowers either
so maybe it's not surprising that he
turns to the world of professional
wrestling pretty much
immediately since that's where you can
earn money by beating people up
really the only people beta originally
seems to like
aunt may and uncle ben and even they've
got to buy him a brand new microscope to
get any kind
of affection out of him and then of
course peter refuses to stop that thief
in a television station
and well you probably know what happens
next over here uncle ben
with uncle ben dead at the robbers hands
peter grows up fast
and while he probably needed a tragedy
of that magnitude to bring him to his
senses it doesn't change the fact that
he was kind of horrible
during his pre-powered days at the very
least however peter himself seems to be
aware of that
which is why he'll be guilty about ben's
demise until the end of his days
it's hard to think of two marvel
characters who are more popular than
wolverine and spider-man
naturally you'd assume that their 80s
team-up spider-man vs wolverine
would be nothing more than pure joyous
fan service rather than a grim action
story that ends with spider-man
accidentally beating a woman to death
well you'd have assumed wrong after
spider-man fails to stop the
assassination of some former kgb
operatives peter parker decides to give
up the web-slinging life for good
and heads to germany to chase a story
with fellow daily bugle reporter ned
leeds
meanwhile wolverine hears about the dead
kgb spies
and immediately identifies the killer as
charlie one of his old mercenary buddies
tracking her to germany wolverine runs
into peter parker
and pretty much immediately identifies
him as spider-man
logan then tells parker to go home which
would have worked if ned leeds hadn't
just been killed in their hotel room
wolverine and spider-man tracked down
charlie separately and then joined
forces to find her again
after she escapes a kgb sanctioned hit
eventually wolverine meets up with
charlie in a cemetery where she asks
wolverine to kill her before the kgb
can spider-man misreads the situation
and attacks wolverine
accidentally punching charlie in the
brawl that follows
unfortunately spider-man has super
strength and while wolverine could have
survived the blow
charlie most definitely doesn't in
amazing spider-man vol 2
issue 51 a green-skinned menace named
digger begins stalking a bunch of new
york's old mob hideouts and killing the
gangsters he finds inside
that puts a local don mr ferrelli into a
panic
thankfully he has a solution hire
spider-man to work as his bodyguard
spider-man turns farrelly down of course
citing moral reasons
until ferrelli offers to pay spider-man
ten thousand dollars a day
plus expenses at which point peter
parker immediately falls
placing him firmly in the employee of
the mob technically ferelli doesn't ask
spider-man to do anything against the
law but defending for relief so he can
carry on running his illegal smuggling
enterprise is suspect enough as mary
jane rightly observes still
parker quickly settles into the
jet-setting life of a professional
criminal
along the way he discovers that digger
is actually a composite of 13 gangsters
already killed back in the 50s
whose bodies were buried in a chemical
dump before a gamma bomb fused them
together and brought them all back to
life
where do all these guys come from
spider-man promises to stop digger
but like a true mobster racist has raped
to twelve thousand dollars a day
before long digger reveals himself but
the gamma radiation that melded all the
corpses together begins to wear out
until he quite literally falls to pieces
in a battle with spider-man after the
job is finished spider-man hands over a
tape full of evidence to the nypd
ferrelli is arrested and parker in one
admittedly decent act of redemption
uses the money to open a library funny
how things work out isn't it
most spider-man fans would like to
forget the sins past storyline in which
peter parker learns that before her
death his girlfriend gwen stacy
gave birth to the twin children of his
number one nemesis
norman osborne many spider-man fans
actually have forgotten the follow-up
plotline since remembered which sees
spidey travelling to france
and teaming up with gwen's daughter
sarah who as it turns out
totally has the hots for him this is
creepy for a whole bunch of reasons
to start with sarah looks almost exactly
like gwen
and parker's resulting confusion implies
that he was more attracted to gwen's
looks than her personality
secondly sarah is actually younger than
10 years old
she just ages faster than normal thanks
to the green goblin serum coursing
through her blood so she's not an adult
even if she looks like one finally sarah
and her brother gabriel
grew up believing that peter parker was
their father thanks to norman who wanted
to turn the twins against spider-man
but that doesn't stop this from
happening unfortunately
no one's really in the right ear sarah
spends most of their adventure flirting
with parker and he doesn't exactly tell
her to back off either
still at the very least you could put
sarah's weirdness down to trauma and
lack of experience
what's his excuse in spider-man the
other peter parker gets some bad news
he's going to die and nobody can do
anything to stop it
not his physician dr castillo who first
gives peter his terminal diagnosis
not doctor strange who claims peter's
illness is mystical
and not physical in nature and certainly
not the vampiric spider hunter morlan
who returns from beyond the grave to
beat spider-man within an inch of his
life
but it's actually more learn who comes
out of the encounter the worse for wear
while peter recovers in the hospital his
body undergoes a strange transformation
his eyes transform into bug-like spheres
and his skin hardens
turning into a kind of exoskeleton in
short peter becomes more spider than man
and a morlan shows up at the hospital to
kill mary jane and feast on parker's
remains spider-man's new bestial
instincts kick into full gear a stinger
emerges from parker's arm and pins
moreland to the ground
after which this new and improved
spider-man proceeds to eat his foe alive
marlin crumbles into dust as parker's
body gives out but it's not really the
end for either of them spider-man ends
up stuck in a cocoon
and emerges a little while later with a
whole bunch of new powers while moreland
is resurrected by a group of cultists
and
ends up menacing the entire multiverse
you know comic book stuff
the catch phrase from marvel's epic
civil war events was whose side are you
on but unless you've got a seriously
messed up moral compass
it's pretty clear that tony stark was a
bad guy for one stark is one of the
biggest cheerleaders for the superhuman
registration act which most people
agreed was a pretty flagrant civil
rights violation
on top of that however he also creates a
psychopathic
thor clone gets black goliath and
captain america killed and imprisons his
enemies in a negative zone
for some reason spider-man doesn't just
go along with all of this but actually
becomes one of stark's main supporters
too
peter parker even amassed on live
television exposing his identity to the
world and becoming the poster boy for
the superhuman registration act in the
process
spider-man's decision kicks the civil
war into overdrive and the argument
could be made that most of the bloodshed
that follows
could have been avoided if peter had
stuck to his guns unfortunately the
consequences are dire
not just for the marvel universe but for
parker's friends and family too
liz allen one of peter's oldest friends
abandons him as a result of his
dishonesty
as does j jonah jameson for obvious
reasons
with spider-man's identity exposed
peter's family also becomes a target for
super villains everywhere
including the kingpin who puts out a hit
on the whole parka clan
mary jane avoids the attack but our maid
doesn't and in order to save her life
peter is forced to make one of the worst
decisions of his life
there's nothing more dangerous than
being one of spider-man's lovers gwen
stacy is tossed off a bridge by the
green goblin
betty brandt discovers that her husband
is a super villain and goes a little bit
off the rails after he's killed mary
jane watson
well what hasn't happened to her but
while his lady friends suffer and die
peter will do almost anything for
his dear aunt may anything sure that
hasn't stopped may from dying once or
twice but if he can
peter will do everything in his power to
keep her alive even if that means
throwing his other loved ones under the
bus
in the aftermath of spider-man civil war
and mass king mae gets caught in the
crossfire when the kingpin targets
peter's family
as she hovers near death peter scours
the globe for a way to save her that's
when he's approached by mephisto
who is as far as marvel comics is
concerned quite literally the devil
mephisto offers to save may
and erase spider-man's secret identity
from the public record
but in return peter will have to give up
his marriage to mary jane
after consulting with mj parker accepts
thereby ruining his relationship with
his wife
and sacrificing their missing but
perhaps still alive daughter
who mephisto uses to taunt beta after he
makes his decision
putting aside the obvious fact that
faustian bargains rarely work out well
the one more dave's storyline makes it
very clear where spider-man's priorities
really lie it's obvious that peter
parker cares about army more than anyone
else
but that's not enough either he also
wants her all to himself
at least that's what it looks like
whenever mei starts to get close to a
man
other than peter spider-man interferes
and ruins everything
first off there's mae's husband ben
parker who dies after spider-man decides
he can't be bothered to stop a petty
crook
next in amazing spider-man issue 131
spider-man interrupts mae's wedding to
dark and leaves her groom to die in an
explosion on a crummy canadian island
her third serious boyfriend a gambler
named nathan lubinsky
passes away from a heart attack after
spider-man ruins his get-rich-quick
scheme
previously he had saved a casino owner
named raymond trask from assassination
at the hands of the vulture
thereby putting may and nathan in the
villains process and that's just the
beginning
when mei has a fling with edwin jarvis
the avengers butler
peter's deal with mephisto in one more
day wipes their relationship from
existence
in the recent clone conspiracy arc peter
refuses to let the mysterious medical
company
new you treat mae's third husband j
jonah jameson's father for a mysterious
disease
eventually peter changes his mind but by
then it's too late
and jay jameson is dead that's not a
great track record of course
and what's the common thread that
connects the end of each and every
relationship
why spider-man of course still may
manages to get a modicum of revenge
albeit unintentionally
when peter and dr octopus switch brains
at the beginning of the superior
spider-man
their memories merge giving pizza a
truly horrifying new perspective
on their relationship
parker luck indeed check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]